AJ starts off this hour in Charlotte
North Carolina
aaj welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi
Dave I was hoping you could help me I'm
wondering whether or not I'm ready to
buy our house or if I need to rent for a
few years um I don't need you to help me
with that okay what we teach folks to do
the best way to buy a home because we
want the home to be a blessing rather
than a curse and sometimes people when
they're broke and they buy a house the
house beats them up financially and it's
you know because it's kind of taught
everybody thought walks around talking
about buying a house as if it's always a
good thing and it's not if you're not
ready so we teach people to be out of
debt have an emergency fund of three to
six months of expenses
plus a good strong down payment and then
not buy a house where the payment is
more than 1/4 of your take-home pay on a
15-year fixed and that's the guidelines
we've used for years around here now
that's kind of countercultural because
everybody in the culture runs around
going by us by us miles by house you
know as if you're some kind of a you
know some kind of a reprobate or
something if you haven't bought a house
while you're broke but if you're sitting
with a car payment a student loan
payment
you know boat payment and everything
else payment payment payment and you
know you you buy a house the stinking
house is gonna beat the snot out of you
that makes sense yeah so I mean baby
step three right now good and I surely
because I don't think a ton of money
right now
but I I project them when my income is
gonna increase pretty significant X
three to five years mmm-hmm what do you
know if I could maybe buy a house and
then kind of grow into it if that makes
sense what do you do business I'm
currently a service technician on
capital equipment
I'll be kind of changing roles over the
next few years and the sales mean
eventually running day-to-day so how old
are you 24 good and how much do you make
I take home between eighteen hundred and
twenty six hundred a month depending on
versus yeah okay well once you get out
of baby step three if you saved up a
good down payment and you met those
guidelines that I'm talking about based
on your current income not your future
income and you want to buy an
inexpensive it's gonna be an inexpensive
a little starter house or starter condo
of some kind that's an okay thing to do
it's not the end of the world it might
be that it's okay for you to rent for a
couple more years until your income
because I suspect your incomes going to
more than double in the next three years
right which we change that house yeah
that would change the house you could
afford right absolutely so I mean it's
not a sin to rent for a little while in
your 20s what I don't want folks doing
is being a renter their whole lives
because you've missed out on a huge lift
to your financial situation
homeownership is good for your long-term
but the rush to do it quickly and
prematurely will damage you you see what
I'm saying yeah yeah that makes a lot of
sound yeah so I don't know I don't want
you buying a house because you think
you're gonna make five thousand a month
based on five thousand a month and no I
don't want you buying a house until you
finish your emergency fund and you have
a good down payment so if you were to
buy you know next spring which is
probably how long it's gonna take you to
get to that point you're gonna buy
something fairly conservative and you
know in three years you might be moving
again which would be okay there's
nothing wrong with that okay nothing
like that but you just keep aiming at
that right right and so okay I mean
let's say you're I'm guessing you're
single right that's right okay so I'm
you know let's say you're 27 and you had
bought a next spring you buy a little
sixty or eighty thousand dollar condo
right and you get the stinking thing
paid off that's right you know then you
sell it and buy another property and you
take on a little bit of a mortgage and
get it paid off in a couple years you're
still heading on your 10-year plan to
have a nice paid for property right yeah
no I didn't think about that now you
might be doing you might be doing a bit
of a two-step here but that's okay you
know you get you can get around do that
but just don't go too
fast into these things don't push too
hard into these things so good question
very good discussion thanks for calling
in